we're gonna do a little what's more
likely and the first topic obviously
deals with Jared Stidham what's more
likely as the week 1 starter for the New
England Patriots will it be Jared
Stidham or will it be third time Patriot
Brian Hoyer well I think this is an easy
one it's Jared spit him all the way you
know again Mike you've heard me say it
for the last few weeks I think you heard
he said towards the end of the football
season
you know I know they hold Jared Stidham
in high regard in New England I think
they see a lot of the same qualities
they saw in Tom Brady as a young
quarterback they see them in Jared
Siddim good leader big arm smart loves
football professionnel all the time I
think he is their guy for at least this
year and you know we'll see where it
goes but I think they're planning on him
taking over the reins and and being
their guy for quite some time yeah I
agree with you there and I think that
the addition of Brian Hoyer is more
about having an in-house mentor for
Jared Stidham than anything else and you
can you can create the impression that
Hoyer's competing for the starting job
to push Jared Stidham so he doesn't get
complacent and think he's he's been
handed the reins but I think Hoyer is
there to support Stidham to help get him
ready to be that veteran presence who
knows the system inside and out that
Jared Stidham otherwise wouldn't have so
I think that's gonna help stood him get
even better in horrors always gotten
rave reviews for being a great team and
I feel bad for him his ship never really
actually came in in the NFL every time
he gets a chance to play he ends up
getting an injury concussion whatever
remember he was playing for the Browns
and tore an ACL on a Thursday night and
it just it it it never really clicks for
Brian Hoyer so I think his best play is
to be the support structure for Jared
Stidham and we'll see what they have in
Stidham they're gonna find out you know
maybe it's somebody else next year but
they're gonna find out this year whether
or not student can be the guy they are
they're gonna find out you're right you
know I know we talked about yesterday to
Sydow you know if you went back and
watched his junior year you'd go oh he's
a first-round pick the team fell apart
around him and Auburn and we're in the
day and age where when the team falls
apart we just blamed the quarterback
even though he had like the worst pass
protection than any quarterback I watch
the draft last year but you know you
said all the right things with Hoyer
that's right Smita was the guy lawyer is
a Class A backup I mean as far as he's
he's got talent so he can still make the
offense go but he's got no ego and he
will help Jared Stidham in the classroom
on the field just little nuances things
did Brian lawyers learned over the years
about certain plays that even him and
Tom Brady had talked about so he'll be
able to pass some of that knowledge on
and be like a calm little you know angel
on Jared Stidham shoulder there next up
who's more likely to draft a quarterback
in 2020 Washington or Carolina well I
mean I'm neither I mean I pick one of
the other but when I don't like either
choice I'm saying neither okay III just
think that the Redskins right now
they're they got a full house and you
mentioned earlier in the show we don't
know where Alex Smith stands in this
conversation yet so I think they would
be silly to at least spend a high draft
pick in Washington you have Dwayne
Haskins you got a guy like Kyle Allen
now who I think is a really high-level
backup quarterback in football and
Carolina no they're riding with Teddy
Bridgewater until they see different to
you know they invested money in him
they're gonna see what he's got as they
build their football team and then a
year to two years from now or two years
from now and they can get on Teddy
Bridgewater's contract if they have to
be and though he's not the guy then
they'll get back into the quarterback
market but I think right now these two
teams are gonna stay a pack see I think
caroline is more likely to do it because
Matt rule will have insights into the
quarterbacks some of the quarterbacks
who are in the draft pool because he
will have seen them he will have studied
them and when you look at it they've got
Teddy Bridgewater to be the starter for
the next couple of years
PJ Walker the guy who's got the
connection of Matt rule and then you
bring in I not you know it doesn't have
to be first-round fifth sixth seventh
round or a guy who you know there are
some general managers you think every
year you should be drafting a
quarterback and develop him and if you
get lucky maybe he becomes your starter
maybe you flip him to another team to
get something in return like Carolina
just did
with with Ryan Allen undrafted they got
a fifth round pick out of him so I think
Matt rules gonna at some point in the
draft fifth sixth seventh round he's
gonna see somebody there who's available
and he's gonna say I know that guy I
respect that guy and and when you
consider that the opportunities to meet
people this year have the visits that's
gone a lot of the stuff that you
ordinarily would rely on to get to know
prospects is out the window your
pre-existing knowledge of a guy from
your time at the college level I think
that makes Matt rule of all the coaches
who are breaking in this year and really
of any of the coaches he's in a unique
position because he knows more about
these college players than anybody else
cuz he's the only guy out of 32 coaches
who just came from that world ya know he
does he's got a great advantage he's
seen a lot of these guys in person
crossover film so he will have a great
feel for this class coming out in the
draft next year's class even a year
after that he's gonna have an inside
look because he is gonna seen a lot of
these guys since they were in high
school to watching high school film with
him you know trying to figure out
whether he wants to give him a
scholarship to bail or a temple or
wherever that wherever the hell else he
was but you know yeah I blade round
picks
I wasn't really counting that as what we
were talking about for this you know
Redskins or Panthers conversation I
could certainly be tonight I wasn't
gonna bring up like oh yeah they might
draft all Johnny from this in the sixth
round oh great you know I understand
that and I understand like what's more
likely to draft a quarterback Washington
a Carolina you have access to the same
document I have access to mr. coffee mug
I understand but I just don't give a
damn about us next when Washington
quarterback Dwayne Haskins this season
more likely to be benched for bad play
or more likely to start for the entire
year I'm gonna start from the entire
year at the end of last season and I
think all the signals that Ron Rivera
has been said to Dwayne Haskins which is
you know
get on your P's and Q's they better be
on your game and be a better
professional but I think we've all heard
some of the stories from Dwayne Haskins
that it was not tip-top for the most
part of the year last year as far as
dedication you know all the things you
want to see from a quarterback who's
gonna be the face of your franchise I
think you got a hold of that towards the
end of the year to make them feel better
but between Ron Rivera's comments Kyle
Allen you know coming into town they're
getting the poker out there just to
stick it onto Dwayne Haskins to make
sure he knows like hey this is not gonna
be just a red carpet rollout to where
all we drafted you in the first round
and you're the man no matter what now
they're gonna make him earn it Ron
Rivera wants to send that message to his
whole team that anybody's got to earn it
but I still think Dwayne Haskins will be
the guy if you make me choose that
either of those two options see I think
he's more likely to be benched for bad
play not necessarily his own but the
team's bad play because you get to the
end of the year you want to see what
some of these other guys can do you give
Alex Smith a cup of coffee let him get
back out on the field you you put Kyle
Allen out there and see what he can do I
just think it's more likely we see
Dwayne Haskins get the hook at some
point you know what with with Bruce
Arians in the buccaneers I allowed
myself to think for a while that the the
messages coming from Aryans were just
aimed at at something other than him
telling the truth about how he feels I'm
starting to think with Ron Rivera he's
just telling the truth about how he
feels this isn't a guy he drafted this
isn't a guy he's worked with and he is
concerned based on what he saw last year
what he's picked up about whether or not
Dwayne Haskins has that maturity to
embrace the job and do everything he
needs to do and as we talked about
earlier the challenge is gonna be even
more pronounced this year by virtue of
the fact that in the offseason God's
gonna be left to their own devices and
they're gonna be expected to get
themselves ready without the benefit of
being in a group and that's gonna make
it harder for Haskins to prove to Ron
Rivera he's got the requisite maturity
all right which quarterback is more
likely to make the final roster in
Carolina PJ Walker freshly signed from
the XFL or West Virginia great will
Grier a third-round pick in 2019 all
right get your Kleenex out okay cuz I
know this is gonna hurt you
I don't know okay I know like that you
just I know you're a consumer you can
say you're a West Virginia Mountain near
full ball fan but yes I think it's PJ
Walker I mean one I just think he's more
talented than will Grier you know the
one thing we saw from PJ Walker man hey
he can scramble around the pocket extend
plays he's a pretty high level thrower
of the football accurate you know can
scramble and run when he does get
outside of the pocket will Grier
yeah it's hey listen I'm not rooting
against the guy I just don't see that
type of talent as far as being able to
compete with PJ Walker on a day-in
day-out basis so I got Walker no doubt
here yeah and walkers got the edge he
knows my rule look what whoa yeah look
at look at what Matt rule is doing with
the quarterbacks he inherited Cam
Newton's gonna be gone Kyle Allen
started 12 games last year is gone will
Grier hey sorry thanks for the memories
thanks thanks for losing those last two
games to help us get the seventh overall
pick that was the plan when David Tepper
suggested benching Kyle Allen input will
Grier and I don't know that for sure but
that's what I would have done I've said
it many times and I'll continue once you
know you're not make it to the playoffs
evaluate your young players so you can
lose as many games as you can and rise
up the rankings they got that seventh
overall pick in part because Grier
played those last two games I agree with
you I think he's going to be gone and I
could see him get traded to a team that
you know liked him last year coming out
maybe like the third-round level but
maybe you know this is gonna be the
bookend to getting a fifth round pick
for a guy they didn't draft at all in
Kyle Allen maybe they get a fifth round
pick or a sixth round pick for will
Grier and move on alright one more
with Travis Frederick now retired as the
Cowboys
Center what's more likely for Ezekiel
Elliott this year leading the league in
rushing or falling short of last year's
output of 1357 rushing yards
I'm gonna go falling short of last
year's rushing of 1357 yards I mean I
just don't I don't think he's gonna lead
the league in rushing I mean that's my
big point you know one III gotta see a
change in Ezekiel Elliott he's still
really good don't get me wrong I'm not
trying
sit here and go oh man but I was
disappointed as you know and we
mentioned and we showed videos during
the season last year there was a whole
lot of runs where he got tackled and
went oh there was a lot of meat left on
that bone you know a really top-flight
running back would have made that guy
miss and got 30 extra yards so I'm not
gonna say he's a league leader he just I
don't think he's as talented as some of
the Christian McCaffrey Dalvin cook Nick
Chubb who else am I missing say qualm
Barkley you know that I say I was
concerned with the physical look of
Ezekiel Elliott last year lack of
explosion lack of long speed didn't run
people over with physicality like I had
seen him I I really hope he's having a
good off season kind of get him get
himself back on track and I also think
we need to take into account the Mike
McCarthy offense and I know they're
sticking with the offense they had last
year for now but McCarthy should have
fingerprints on it
and last year we saw the transition away
from the run first approach to more dak
Prescott Mike McCarthy became the head
coach of the Green Bay Packers in 2006
and the highest rushing total during
that window of oh six through 2018 was
Ryan grant in 2009 with twelve hundred
and fifty three yards that's the most
anyone ever ran for in the Green Bay
offense with Mike McCarthy as the head
coach so I think as eql it's gonna be
under 1357 I think we're gonna see more
passing and and I agree with you look we
fully supported 2zq Elliott doing what
he had to do to get paid last year but
he hasn't been the same guy since then
you put those two things together and I
think there's reason to think he'll be
south of 13 57 you make good points
we'll see Mike McCarthy I will say to
this I mean you did have Aaron Rodgers
and Brett Favre which probably made them
towards the past game a little bit more
but Prescott Amari Cooper and some other
Russian receivers to go along with it
and let's not forget this Mike to I mean
when Mike McCarthy turns on the film of
the 2019 Dallas Cowboys he's going to
look at the film goddamn this Tony
Pollard kid he's pretty good we need to
give him the ball
and I think that will take away from
Ezekiel Elliott stats as well
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports